for millions of Indians clean drinking
water is a luxury these twice daily
deliveries are a lifeline for Sanjay
camp in Delhi children like these and
their families the basics of daily life
come before basic health care but India
is on the brink of a health revolution
the government wants to offer advanced
treatment to half a billion of the
poorest people but it is not using the
NHS model this will not be free for all
at the point of use instead 500 million
people will get health insurance they
say it's the largest healthcare project
ever attempted others that it is a folly
which will fail the poor we traveled
across India to examine an experiment on
a scale to draw even the foundation of
the NHS
government hospitals like this one
outside Delhi are the closest most
Indians get to NHS style treatment for
hundreds of millions which is the only
option it costs one rupee to register
just over a penny but after that
treatment is free up to a point
they see 600 patients a day here and the
doctors are besieged symptoms diagnosis
descriptions are dealt with in minutes
sanathana dick Avedon about privacy is
less important place in the queue we
find people with diseases that have been
almost eradicated from the West
this woman has brought her daughter who
has tuberculosis one Haiti loss of
sanitation not knowledge or about the
awareness power difference it's a
disease of poverty yes and you have to
deal with nitrogen malnutrition that's
why they got that
if you need an operation you have to pay
abdominal surgery costs around five
pounds and it's more for an extended
hospital stay one surgeon does around 30
a week here the government insurance
scheme would cover the costs this will
be an excellent idea and it will do
great wonders for the poor people if
this project is implemented properly at
the dispensary there's a clamor for
basic antibiotics and other medicines
available at any chemist only here they
have x-ray though not always enough
Porter's the maternity ward is always
busy too
but these walls tell their own stories
this is the reality of health care for
most Indians the Constitution guarantees
free treatment as the government spends
just 1% of GDP on health that only goes
so far
most pay out of their own pockets
complex treatment is beyond reach for
many the government insurance scheme is
meant to change that extending
operations and cancer treatment to up to
500 million people it's known as Modi
care after Prime Minister Narendra Modi
for an idea of how it might work
we traveled south to Bangalore to the
largest Heart Hospital world
it's a private hospital that 50% of
treatments have paid for by a state
insurance scheme or charity and
subsidized by paying patients
in a country where for people dying from
heart attacks every minute the core
business is surgery
in the pediatric intensive care unit
children recover from life-saving
operation ISM
on an adult ward we met mrs. Tina Papa
she waited for an operation to repair a
40 heart valve paid for by a state
scheme I haven't had to pay any money
out of my own pocket an hour later she
was in the theater her heart stopped
and attached to a bypass machine
preserve the precious one well repair it
in such a way that the leak stops they
don't need to take their blood thinning
targets lot of these specials come from
very rural background so that saves them
from doing the blood tests taking the
tablets and is it a success as far as
you very nicely
less than two hours after the operation
began a second surge encloses the heart
right no the heart is arrested
it is lakeya nurse there's no beating of
the heart like a dead heart and if not
beating so you can see heart is like
this slowly and oculus Li
bring back to life mr. Cheney papa made
a full recovery
Oh shame down a little life stone
because he's moving somehow kilometers
reading Butler's he can't go beyond that
she had to take the rest
she found claims stills were total three
floors no she will jump like anything
there are five operating theaters
running simultaneously here this is just
one around 30 operations they'll do here
today the senior surgeon goes from
theater to theater for the crucial part
of each procedure and this production
line technique has allowed them to drive
down the cost of heart surgery around
$1500 bringing an image of many more
people the man behind it is dr. Devi
Shetty he trained in the NHS was Mother
Teresa's personal physician and runs a
private health care empire that now
includes 25 hospitals we believe that
India will become the first country in
the world to dissociate health care from
affluence we will prove to the world
that the wealth of the nation has
nothing to do with the quality of health
care its citizens can enjoy if you
collect half a dollar from individual
mobile phone subscribers every month we
can offer surgical care for the entire 1
billion population poor people in
isolation are very weak but together
they are very strong dr. Shetty is
convinced the private sector should
deliver treatment and says India has a
lesson for the NHS like every system it
has to undergo changes like different
business model of delivering NHS health
care once that happens it will be a
great system and it will last I am very
very proud of NHS Indian health care is
rooted in the past even as it looks to
the future at the South Korea Institute
a medical center that looks like a spa
royalty in the rich pay more than 600
pounds a night for Ayurvedic therapy
practice for more than 5,000 years it
uses compounds of herbs and minerals and
oils it's recognized by the Department
of Health and there are more than
200,000 qualified doctors its scientific
value may be questionable but it's been
estimated 80 percent of the population
have been treated with Ayurveda sakis
founder says this ancient discipline can
help india's problem is more than now
even there are pockets of places
communicable disease the problem but
majority replaces modern communicable
diabetes for example and these rarity
diseases cardiac diseases these are the
major killers
so all this condition actually lifestyle
modifications the most important along
with the diet along with the treatment
in the herbal treatment and where are
necessary Vesta medical treatments I
evader looks more like this for ordinary
people this lady's injured ankle has
been treated with lime and honey she's
had to come to this clinic for a pain
killing injection with 3 hours drive
east of Bangalore at a rural primary
care center serves 15,000 people living
in a 30 kilometre radius many of them
are farmers he like this man who crashed
his moped a single doctor sees around
150 patients every day and they are
getting all the care also health care
they are getting so because district
hospital is very far far from here so it
is very good for them to take it from
here
and otherwise they would have to pay and
yeah and they have to pay and they have
to go to private sector so that is very
difficult for them to go there to
improve public health the state
employees health workers who go house to
house on a mission to educate
[Music]
Fator it's four days old was born by
cesarean section weighing less than
three and a half pounds it grandpa
Lulu look Jessie infant mortality in
India is coming down but it's still
higher than the global average and worse
than in comparable developing nations
like China and Brazil indeed if there is
a pregnant woman then we give her
information about nutrition and the kind
of food she should be eating about the
vaccination schedules and the general
care she should be taking yeah with our
comic on there Botello motivational
booster these are the people the
government say they want to help the
rural poor living in a place where the
lack of basic public health measures
still causes serious illness and they're
lucky here they at least have a doctor
on their doorstep this new government
scheme promises to do is provide a
financial safety net when their needs go
way beyond or can be looked after here
India's emerging middle class presents
another challenge this fluent generation
is experiencing a growth in lifestyle
conditions like diabetes which will make
the healthcare landscape even more
complex it is a double burden some
campaigners believe makes basic public
health a greater priority than the
government's Insurance Scheme
and private care there's absolutely no
evidence that a country like India which
is developing which has a huge number of
poor you know communities and poor
people we cannot afford the kind of
model that you know this - Bharat ahmadi
k represents the private sector has no
interest absolutely in climate eok- kind
of health care these children can
already expect to live longer than
previous indian generations lifting them
out of poverty may do more for their
health in the short term that Modi care
it is a plan tailored to the challenge
of providing health care to more than a
billion people for a fraction of the
cost of the Western model
NHS founded nie Bevin said the service
would be the envy of the world given a
choice India has put its faith in social
insurance and the private sector if it
succeeds it may lead the way for the
developing world
Paul Kelso sky news
[Music]